[Aplausos]
olá
o dia meu pai pediu para que eu tirasse
as rodinhas
mas eu não queria vocês que têm filhos
aqui acreditam neles você acredita nos
seus filhos ou se já sonharam por eles
antes mesmo dele ser e eles nascerem
definindo coisas como qual profissão
animais seguir qual esporte uma pática
ou até mesmo qual animal de estimação mt
quando você define qual profissão seu
filho vai ter coisas horríveis acontecem
com ele no futuro porque ele vai não
acabar gostando do que você definiu você
não sei se o filho é seu filho ele pai
ter um sonho diferente do seu
é um aspecto e se você puxa ele pra
colocar na mesma rota que você seguiu
evo geralmente os pais fazem isso por
medo medo que o filho é porque é um como
caminha como você digitar de bicicleta e
você coloca se sozinhos por seu filho
não caísse para de fato no chão
só que você tem que decorar só que
muitos pais acabam colocando realmente
só jeans e não deixam os filhos em
livres mesmo que ele se espatife se
espatifar no chão todos
então quando os pais escolhe qual
profissão seu filho vai querer seguir o
que seu filho mais que é isso que esse
país tem medo
eles têm medo que o filho caia e com o
que acontece quando você define isso seu
filho não é feliz
seu filho vai para seguir sim o seu
conselho porque você é o pai dele e
acredita geralmente que o país sempre tá
certa o que muitas vezes se realmente
estão sem muitas vezes certa mas quando
você define essa profissão ele não vai
gostar
ele vai seguir e quando eu estiver velho
mais velho
tipo 50 a 70 anos
ele vai lá e vai estar arrependido de
ter feito isso porque ele não vai estar
a debater uma posição que ele não vai
estar gostando que ele está fazendo está
vivendo de algo que ele nunca gostou de
fazer e muitos tentam voltar atrás mas
não consegue e morre
infelizes se você acha que isso
realmente é um pouco melhor o gramático
um pouco muito fora da caixa que não
acontece está enganada
uma pesquisa feita projeto chamado rb
renda básica universal para quem nunca
ouviu falar e objetivo desse projeto é
dar uma renda o suficiente para a
sobrevivência de qualquer pessoa
independente do que ela está sofrendo
hoje e nesta pesquisa foi feita uma
pergunta o que você faria se ganhar sua
renda
muitos dos participantes responderam eu
largar o emprego sabe significa que
todos esses que responderam não estão
felizes com a profissão que seguiu que
largariam uma oportunidade eu e muitas
vezes os pais não diretamente escolhe
com a profissão lhe o seu filho vai
seguir mas sim quando escolhe qual
esporte seu filho uma prática porque não
acredita que o filho consegue escolher
um esporte deficiente ou você acha que
aquele esporte ou melhor pra ele fazer e
como quando ele está fazendo alguma
coisa que ele não gosta o que acontece é
que ele não vai estar querendo fazer
aquilo
ele vai estar numa posição de não gostar
de fazer algo eu acredito que vocês já
tenham talvez em um momento de suas
vidas
que efeito uma coisa você é obrigado
obrigado a fazer mas você não queria
fazer um gol lá vá fazer há todo tipo de
desculpa o círio na terra para não fazer
a mesma coisa que seu filho vai fingir
doente vai duvide que dormiu mais do que
deveria fazer tudo para evitar e pressa
pra esse esporte ou ativa
deu pra ele e quando ele está fazendo
isso lê durante quando ele está lá ele
vai estar infeliz não vai ter amigos que
nunca prometi não vai ter ninguém com
interesse em comum lá e ele vai ser
triste porque nós não porque ele está
fazendo o que ele não gosta mas porque
os colegas
o professor e você irá chamar atenção
puxa e está indo lá e tá perdendo tempo
é sim e muito por dentro
realmente esse trecho porque ele vai
sentir inútil de não estar de não estar
fazendo aquilo direito mas não consegue
porque está realmente não querendo fazer
aquilo e não é só fora de casa que
acontece lá dentro
quando você escolhe qual o animal de
estimação o seu filho vai ter quando se
escolhe cônico animal de estimação seu
filho vai ter é porque você não acredita
que ele tem capacidade de escolher qual
animal de estimação ele vai querer ter
que ele vai conseguir cuidar desse
animal de estimação que ele não é
encarada incapacitado por isso e você
escolhe essa esse animal de estimação e
em geral o animalzinho de estimação que
você já saiba cuidar não é fácil e
talvez nenhum talvez nenhuma das vezes
acontece isso e quando você faz isso
muitas vezes é os filhos não conseguem
gerar empatia você quer partir para o
animalzinho porque ele é seu basicamente
e seu então é muito complicado pra ele
gerar empatia não vai se importar com o
animal de estimação e alguns casos mal
tratos
realmente quem como você escolhe seu
animal de estimação e os pais não fazem
isso como eu disse porque acho que o
filho não tem responsabilidade
suficiente mas os pais acabam chegando
muito que na verdade isso é a solução
porque quando você tem animal de
estimação por você sempre está treinando
só responsabilidade de todo dia você
fique lá limparei alimentar
da água dá atenção e eu sei se de
prática essa é a chevron ea gatinha eu
peguei ela da rua e ela era bem
pequenininha
ela teve os seus filhinhos e é como ela
está hoje aqui e durante nesse meio
tempo e até hoje eu limpo a us o eu
limpo airinho todo dia eu dou a
alimentação não é comidinha eu limpo
água eo filtro eu tô atenção para eles e
não só eu tenho irmãos basicamente eu
nunca tive que nunca tive um irmão os
pais eles são basicamente os meus irmãos
e irmãs na tentativa e eles são meus
irmãos e eu adoro eu adoro eles eu
adorei esse meu tempo e seu filho também
vai gostar
isso é um fato que ele vai adorar ter um
animal de estimação e colheu escolhi
temos gatinhos
eu escolhi ficar com uma gata escolhi
ficar com os três filhotes que ela deu
luz então foi uma experiência muito
legal pra mim e pra minha família e o
sport ele também é muito que os pais
manipulam muito isso mas quando o seu
filho escolhe qual esporte ele vai
seguir ele vai fazer aquilo com o paixão
o amor com carinho e consequentemente
está fazendo isso muito bem feita
eu tive experiência que fazer um esporte
com família e eu fez muitos amigos
durante é eu treinar até com do que foi
o sport com a cabeça erguida
tá que eu que colete azul dando uma
voadora no menino aí e eles termina aí
eliton desde que ele saiu voando no dia
realmente não é legal
e nesse e atrás dele
são todos mas o que estão nos mestres
professora mestre que é mais legal são
os mestres e colegas e amigos que eu fiz
e mesmo o menino que eu tô ficando de
motor aí ele era meu amigo
realmente ele ainda é meu amigo e eu
treinei bastante não só o corpo ea mente
mas como divertir e treinei até mesmo
muito minha responsabilidade pra passar
de faixa até com dor eu cheguei o dia
que eu fiquei treinando até às seis da
manhã fazendo que os movimentos
repetitivos é não é assim aquela empresa
e eu adorei minha família também
inclusive muitas vezes seus filhos que
acabam adorando isso realmente gostando
é fato que eles vão acabar se
selecionado como a profissão porque a
profissão é simplesmente uma
conseqüência do que você gosta de fazer
do que seu filho gosta de fazer
eu adoro expulso e eu quero ser
astronauta e meus pais sempre me
ajudaram sempre me deram rua pra eu ser
astronauta eles como a lei do começo da
palestra
meu pai que lhe tira a rodinha estava
cometa e ele me incentivou para tirar
roger e eu tenho nessa imagem que eu
toco o game e o huji é o game que alega
está há 20 anos de idade espero que se
consiga ver direitinho então e ele é um
gênio chefe da nasa e ele me deu até
mesmo assim o aqui esse uniforme da nasa
e ele me deu a chance de forma nada de
presente e ele é um cara muito bacana
jeff também é um cara muito bacana e ele
é a ponte entre o brasil ea nasa do
evento site 10 e foi uma experiência
muito legal
também conheci o primeiro e único por
enquanto e é astronauta que é o marcos
pontes e realmente acredite eu meus pais
acreditaram realmente mim o que eles
fizeram como disse aqui meus pais meu
pai ele e ele me fez realmente
o que acha disso e foi muito legal mesmo
que naquele dia o sport fecham mas faz
parte da vida realmente faz parte da do
ciclo natural você cai você aprende
então o que eu proponho pra vocês eu
convido vocês a quando seus filhos
estiverem estilo seguro sobre si mesmos
ou quando você tem fim às limitações
você corte
essas limitações e tira a rodinha deles
muito obrigado tenham um ótimo dia
eu sou até as piores
o u1
[Aplausos]